[Musique]
qu'est ce que je découvre ce matin en me
levant
apple vient de sortir un tout nouvel
iphone 7 aux couleurs rouge le 7 et le
7è ce raid product red edition en
édition limitée et gadret dalle existe
dans le but de lutter contre le vih en
reversant de l'argent sur une partie des
sommes allouées directement à l'achat de
ces produits pour apporter de l'argent
directement pour le soin contre le vih
alors c'est vraiment une nouveauté qui
arrive comme ça ça fait quelques temps
il y avait une rumeur qui courrait
dessus n'a rien de bien concret apple la
sortie sur son site directement sans qui
notre sens je dirais annonce officielle
en prenant la parole si ce n'est un
communiqué en tout cas ça sont des
produits qui sont très très bon tu te
retrouves avec un iphone 7 qui est
vraiment superbe
dans cette couleur là et un iphone c'est
plus plus grands très beau aussi
vraiment une superbe couleur sur ses
téléphones en fin de compte tout le
devant va être blanc ça tarde vraiment
d'avoir un contraste de contraster avec
ce rouge qui en rouge qui est vraiment
très très beau par contre effectivement
on va regretter c'est de ne pas avoir le
petit rouge directement autour du bouton
home
après très honnêtement l'inconvénient de
ce produit si tu veux c'est que quand tu
as un téléphone rouge comme ça la
plupart des gens mais une coque de
protection parce que ton téléphone tu as
peur de l'abîmer c'est une tombe s'ils
se passe quoi que ce soit il est rayé il
abîme et efficace donc on met des écrans
des verts sur le ventre entre des écrans
de protection sur le devant et des cocos
tour donc tu habilles ton iphone rouge
qui va te coûter une blinde avec une
protection et on le verra plus c'est
quand même relativement dommage après il
faut quand même noter qu'apple si tu
veux va proposer une coque rouge tu peux
aller voir directement sur son site
et tu vas voir quels tout un ensemble de
produits autour des ces produits red
d'ailleurs on va les voir ensemble tout
de suite acheté raid donner de l'espoir
depuis dix ans notre partenariat avec
red soutient des programmes de lutte
contre le sida qui offre des conseils
des tests et des médicaments empêchant
la transmission du vih à des enfants
pendant la grossesse
la vente de nos produits red a déjà
permis de récolter plus de 130 millions
de dollars
et maintenant nous vous présentons les
fun sept producteurs est d' special
edition acheter raid c'est faire un pas
de plus vers la génération sans sida et
ça c'est vraiment louable en tout
effectivement ce produit qui est très
très sympa chaque achat raid est une
contribution directe au fonds mondial ii
contre le sida qui peut aussi avoir la
coque rouge c'est ce que je te disais
c'est à ton téléphone si tu me prends
acte mais une coque sur un bon téléphone
rouge c'est qu'on leur ait un téléphone
rouge peinte une coque rouge c'est con
par contre effectivement acheté la coque
si tu veux faire une bonne action
je dirai après il ya plein de produits
un qui existent si elle est brassée les
sports de l'apple watch que tu peux
acheter en rouge le casque beats les
employés les enceintes beats l'ipod
shuffle les ipod les coques pour ipad
et voilà tu peux aussi faire rendre mal
en soi ce qui est intéressant c'est
lorsque vous achetez des produits red
nous reversons une contribution au fonds
mondial le fonds mondial le fort mandat
utilise latérite et de cet argent pour
financer des programmes de lutte contre
vih sida
cette contribution via l'aide à des
personnes atteintes du vih au ghana les
autos randa afrique du sud swaziland en
tanzanie au kenya et en zambie et tu
peux faire un don directement si t'as
pas envie de faire cloqué d'un nouvel
iphone au final apple si tu veux faire
un coup double feinte coup double est
super intéressant le premier coup
effectivement ça fait dix ans qu'ils
font savoir qu'ils ont permis de
soutenir je dirais des programmes de
lutte contre le sida en afrique
subsaharienne et va savoir effectivement
que c'est un fléau là bas il ya un vrai
problème de protection il ya un vrai
problème de traitement il ya un vrai
problème d'argent
ça n'a pas résoudre le problème du sida
mais si ça peut aider des gens à voir
une trithérapie garde traitement
efficace c'est bien et ça ne peut pas le
reprocher à apple c'est vraiment top
bravo c'est vraiment une mentalité
américaine 1,5 les grandes entreprises
américaines soutiennent souvent du cose
ya aussi des fondations des choses qu'on
voit assez régulièrement et ça on peut
pas leur poser c'est vraiment top
à côté de ça il faut aussi par pour
apple c'est un coup marketing qui est
extraordinaire c'est à dire que là ils
ont sorti leur iphone 7 l'année dernière
ils sont pas de sortir en septembre
normalement 2010 est un iphone 8 heures
tu peux aller voir la vidéo nous avons
fait un petit peu les rumeurs comment
devrais peut-être en tout cas ce nouveau
téléphone
et là ils sont vraiment dans une phase
de transition donc tout de suite on n'a
pas réellement de nouveaux produits
c'est pas la meilleure période pour les
vendre donc du coup l'idée de sortir un
iphone cette attaque cette coque rouge
puis moi devons faire parler d'eux parce
que c'est une très bonne action c'est
pas juste une couleur un peu bidon puis
c'est vraiment très très belle c'est jus
génial c'est super intelligent ça c'est
un super coup marketing parce que
beaucoup de monde va parler de ça déjà
parce que le téléphone lui même est beau
et puis parce que l'action à soutenir et
tu peux pas dire le contraire
elle est vraiment importante c'est
vraiment bien que apple se positionne au
dessus donc tout le monde en parle ça
fait un coup marketing ça va relancer
les ventes d'apple sur tous ces produits
là parce qu'il n'ya pas que s'il n'y a
pas que l'iphone si tu veux via l'ipad
et l'ipod
il ya les bracelets en plus il annonce
effectivement des modifications de
capacité sur l'iphone et ce en ait pas
de gérer troisième édition qui est un
peu remodelée mais vraiment pas mal de
choses dans le catalogue
et puis tout des bracelets de couleur un
peu printanière pour l'apple watch donc
rouler aussi tu vois tout au début du
printemps ça permet effectivement
d'avoir un peu une collection est de
mettre en avant leur collection
printemps 2010 est je dirais pour
l'apple watch donc c'est un très beau
coup de com pour apple
ça permet de soutenir une bonne action
on ne peut pas dire du mal de ça parce
que fondamentalement c'est intelligent
ça permet de venir en aide à des gens
qui ont besoin réellement de lutter
contre le sida et ça permet de garder
aussi un message très important pour les
gens on parle de la lutte contre le vih
se permet de rappeler qu'il est très
important de se protéger parce que le
vih est toujours là alors effectivement
en afrique subsaharienne et ils n'ont
pas les mêmes traitements est il même
accès aux soins que nous en france avec
la chance déjà qu'on a de la sécurité
sociale de pouvoir payer un traitement
aux trithérapies qui coûte quand même
une blinde
c'est un traitement très lourd à prendre
au quotidien c'est vraiment très très
lourd très compliqué et très fatigant
donc ça c'est une super réaction de la
part d'apple on ne peut qu'applaudir
mais aussi vos lacets je dirais une
belle leçon de marketing à prendre pour
tout le monde donc dis moi ce que t'en
penses est ce que toi tu as le cincle si
c'est ce que tu es chez apple chez
samsung chez un hôte du mois quel est
ton téléphone
dis moi ce que tu penses déjà d'une de
cet iphone 7 est ce que la couleur de
tous le trouvent séduisant parce que tu
auras envie de craquer est ce que tu vas
attendre plutôt l'iphone 8 pour voir un
peu les nouveautés qui vont se présenter
et pas forcément craquer parce que
c'était déjà un iphone 7 où 1 6s moi
j'ai 1 6s
je me vois acheter un set rouge et dans
quelques mois je me rends compte que le
8 est génial et que je veux switcher une
super cher on est quand même sur des
téléphones qui sont agents autour de 900
euros pour le plus petit modèle et pour
le plus gros modèle on est à mille
auront donc on est quand même sur des
produits qui sont très chers tous les 6
mois poser mille euros même si
effectivement au prix de revente
intercâble pause ça reste très
compliquée dis moi ce que t'en penses
dis-moi comment tu trouves ses
téléphones
qu'est-ce que tu te penches de cette opé
marketing d'apple mais moi tout ça en
commentaire on en discute ensemble
n'hésite pas à taïwan yade achète après
un plaisir cette vidéo ta plume un joli
poussent vers le haut
n'hésite pas regarde cette vidéo qui est
très sympa je t'embrasse et je te dis à
très très très vite parce que là j'ai
encore une autre vidéo qui sent le feu
donc moins que je me dépêche et beaucoup
de travail je t'embrasse mon lapin a
très vite ciao